you know firstly
i find you to be extremely philosophical
and much more so than
much more so than the average much much
more so than the average physics
professor i'm curious do you see that
and
and well do you see there firstly is
that true do you feel that's true
i'm happy you asked this question and
uh let me answer
in this way depend on what you mean the
average uh physical professor if you
mean
today's physical professors the answer
is definitely yes
i'm not unique
there are many other like me i mean i
could name many that are
us philosophically or even more
philosophically but the
very very large majority of contemporary
um
physics professors are far less
philosophical however
if you look at the past
um
look uh i don't know 100 years ago in
the in the 20s or 30s of of the of the
20th century
um and if you look just look at the
great scientists at the time uh
schroedinger heisenberg
einstein bour de bogie they were far
more philosophical than me
they were inspired by philosophy reading
philosophy talking philosophy discussing
philosophy
and that includes newton includes
boltzmann includes maxwell includes
faraday
so
i think that the
major advances in science in physics
in the past but also i mean in other
sciences
in biology darvin was enormously
philosophical he was a reading
philosopher he was strongly influenced
by philosophers
um
so i think that
especially in foundational questions of
course if you
the more you go to apply to specific uh
system you're less
you need i mean
you do need a philosophical mind also
for some
some questions in in more more less
foundational questions but but when
you're close to foundational questions
uh uh science in the past uh in the past
i mean until the 60s no
the deep past
uh has been very close
to uh
to philosophy philosophy
questions
influenced by uh by philosophy and and
talking philosophical terms
um
i mean just read einstein einstein
einstein who is a champion of
theoretical physicist for everybody i
would say
uh he
he has read the three main books by kant
before getting being 16.
he was very he read hume he read the uh
chopin hour
uh the philosophical writing of poincare
as a philosopher
and
it's obvious once you go into what he
did that everything he did
was very much affected by this
philosophical thinking
so i think
you're right i am
more
i belong to the to those scientists who
are more philosophical than many others
i think it is a um
a
limitation
of a part of the research today
uh to be
very technical very mathematical very
shut up and calculating
yeah or
or just do mathematical modeling i think
that if you invent a sufficiently
complicated
mathematics uh you've been decent this
and this and this and it's very hard
mathematics and blah blah blah and
that's you're getting close to reality
maybe not
you know some people say don't mistake
the map for the territory
is that what you mean or is it
not precisely worse than that because i
think that a lot of uh
current
working theoretical physics is a map
without a territory
ah okay oh without a territory all right
right now max take mark and i haven't
seen his lectures on this but i'm sure
he would object because he has the
mathematical universe as his
philosophical framework
oh
not at all i mean i think max stegmark
who is a thinker i deeply respect is one
of the most philosophical even more
philosophical than me
i mean he's a
he's a philosopher compared to me i mean
he's a guy who wrote a book claiming
that every
um
every possible coherent mathematically
described universe is
as real as the
our actual one
um
that's deep philosophy that's nothing to
do with direct physics in us it's right
it's it's wonderful speculations
max
uh i mean max has a a technical work as
an astrophysicist but has a
a a
range of wide
philosophical speculations i think we
need more people like max
and less people
who
uh
who just do mathematics without really
asking
what is real reality i'm actually
describing here do you see that there's
not only a lack of philosophical
ideation but perhaps a resistance to it
do you see an aversion to it or do you
just see it as they lack it there's an
absence of it
oh when i say they i mean let's say the
average mathematician or physical or
physicist both both both let's not
forget that stephen weinberg who's a
great scientist of course with major
major results
wrote a book and one of the chapter of
the book the title is against philosophy
and and uh
stephen hawking who is a
very good physicist of course and he did
he had important results not as good as
what weinberg but totally very very
important
it's on the record to say many times
philosophy is dead
um
because now we have signs that solve all
the problems
and which was true but it's wrong
because it doesn't solve the problems it
has a lot of problems by itself
um
and and and so
philosophy is not dead philosophy isn't
constantly interacting with uh um the
reason is
that science is not about uh you know
you make measurement
and then you write an equation
and then you check your equation with
the measurement if it is wrong you throw
it away you try another one that's not
the way sites work the science is
a constant um
changing of the conceptual structure you
use for describing the world
you rearrange things right you call this
together you call this separate you
think differently use different notions
different concepts
uh you know copernicus instead of
thinking the earth the sky you know
there's a mountain the stones in the sky
the sun the moon the planets the stars
he just changed everything he said no no
that's not the rightest thing from this
is the sun and the planets
and the satellites and the planet is the
earth the moon so it's a completely
different rearrangement
of
how to organize the world this is
this
to
to be able to be capable
of this uh conceptor rearrangements
um
you have to think
what you called philosophical uh
thinking that's the kind of thing that
einstein did heisenberg did faraday did
boltzmann did
and that's not what is done
by a lot of theoretical physics who just
think that the only thing you have to do
you know is to write another lagrangian
or
to write another you know map between a
hilbert space and a hilbert space
or a new set of uh
uh uh
of scattering relations yeah and that's
sufficient is that because they want to
play it safe in a sense because when
you're just theorizing mathematically
it's easy to check where you're right
and wrong whereas if you're
philosophizing firstly you can delve
into pseudoscience and not be aware that
you are and it's much easier to wildly
speculate and be incorrect is that
what's behind it like what is behind the
aversion that you see
i think it's cultural i think it's
cultural i mean
many of my colleagues were raised
in the
50s 60s 70s 80s in a moment in which he
became very fashionable
uh to be anti-philosophical
um
this is after the war
uh
the center of science shifted the part
toward the united states from europe
where it was before
uh
a little bit
it's a success of the incredible success
of the physics of the
of the 30s
right the 20s 30s 10th i mean the first
half of the century
i mean the discovery of special
relativity generativity quantum
mechanics quantum field theory
was spectacular uh so good
that then somehow it made sense to say
well stop thinking let's use it
right i mean
we have all these tools that our
forefathers have discovered i mean
that's good let's use it and on the
basis think what has happened on the
basis of
quantum mechanics
uh boom you get you know uh
nuclear physics particle physics con
fundamental condensed matter uh
lasers
all sort of marvels just using the
equations with the doubt by heisenberg
and company
and on the basis of special activity it
took a little bit longer so the end of
the century but suddenly you know you do
relativistic astrophysics cosmology
black hole boom gravitational waves
fantastic just on
on the conceptual ground uh
built in the 20s and 30s
so that the beginning of the century the
physicists were so good
that then people didn't have to think
for various decades just just you apply
apply apply apply but then you need to
stop thinking for a while you get used
to not thinking and you get used to the
idea that it's just mathematical
complications so if you're sufficiently
mathematically skilled
then you will do great physics and there
are people who are
spectacularly mathematically skilled and
drew all the others like them like edwin
edward then is
a great mathematician if there's an
alien it's him
yeah but then he drew an entire
community in doing not physics because
if you think for a moment
edwin
has not got any real
physical result right
he has proven the positive energy
theorem
generativity which have been proved
before and found a better proof of the
positive energy it's a mathematical game
and then he has you know speculated
about string theory and and
and constructed the
games over games that haven't produced
any physics of her
here's a fun question i'm curious if
you've thought much about it so it's a
def it's almost a question of
definitions
what is the universe so one answer is
the universe is everything that there is
so there cannot be an outside to the
universe by definition
by the way when i'm talking about
definitions it seems like that's
there's no point in talking about
definitions themselves are not profound
because they're tautologies
however when i was speaking to jorah
barnett i'm not sure if you know him he
was saying kurt you want me to talk
about proofs and theorems what may be
more important are definitions and
techniques
so let's not
let's not demean definitions so firstly
what is the definition of the what is
the definition of the universe and then
where do the laws stand so are the laws
a part of the universe
um
the different definitions of the of the
universe which are useful
um
and uh
it's good not to confuse them because we
we can use
both of them um
in cosmology
which is a great discipline which have
made very important uh uh
had obtained great results in in the
last decades
uh the universe is not the totality of
thing the universe is the
the description of what we see around us
as the largest scale that we look at it
so
the
that universe is a very small thing
it's lowercase u
it's just not looking at the details
it's what you see if you don't look at
the details but of course the details
says you and i are in the details of
that right sure in that picture
uh that's very useful uh it's a very
strict definition of the universe and
you describe it you know with a scale
factor that grows in the galaxy density
and this kind of things and dark matter
and and so on and so forth
and
that has turned out to be very very
useful because in fact we have learned
a credible story of what has happened
for 14 billion years in the past
and it's a very credible story i mean
it's very convincing once you study it
say yeah good we have evidence for that
but that's not the universe in the sense
that you were asking right it was
you were referring to a different
definition
which is all there is so to say the
totality yeah tantamount to reality
yeah it's a the the
the the totality of the real things the
the totality of of realities
uh i agree that definitions are
um
not
are important accusations yeah they're
not revealed they're not trivial i think
in some sense they are but they give
extreme insight yeah they're great
inside i mean think of the example of uh
i talk about copernicus right if you
start by a definition
you know of uh
earth
and and and the celestial bodies
you you're done you killed copernicus
right you have to redefine things you
have to define planets versus stars
versus satellite and then you go ahead
without this definition you're lost and
then it's a very
uh unintuitive definition planet i mean
why should i put in the same category
the earth which i see around me you know
with the trees the mountain the sky the
birds and this little dot that move out
there which is venus these are
completely different things right no
they're not different things that's the
point you can define them together bingo
you understand how the solar system
works so definitions are crucial now
the tokenitive thing it's a
delicate definition
because of relational quantum mechanics
ah so
uh
you see
if you buy relational quantum mechanics
you cannot
ascribe properties the totality of
things because all properties are really
relative to something else
so there is no
uh
there is no properties the universe has
no property in fact the universe is is
is not a system because a system is
something which can interact with
another system
to reveal its properties to to manifest
its properties
so you
if you buy a relationship quantum
mechanics you only have descriptions of
units from the inside so to say
just keep your universe as a whole you
cannot have it
so
uh
if you take serious relation quantum
mechanics and if you take seriously uh
what several philosophers today
are telling us
uh
i i think foreign ismail is one of them
that
careful because every time we look at
the universe we're looking universe from
the inside as being part of the universe
not from the outside and we often get
confused
because we we take it out of the picture
we think that we can see that totality
of things from the outside and and and
that's wrong and a lot of confusion
about i don't know free will
um
or
um
or
what is knowledge
it's always thinking that we're outside
the universe that's the universe with
its stuff and we are out there looking
at that that's it's not true it's
factually not true
uh so
the universe in the sense of cosmology
is fine it's perfectly good thing
but the universe in the sense of the
totality of thing
uh it's uh it's a notion one should be
very careful with in my opinion for
instance one should not abstract
properties of the universe because how
do
how do you what do you mean this is one
reason i don't believe there is a wave
function of the universe it doesn't make
any sense